Who would have thought that the cheerfully vulgar
stunt show "Jackass" would prove to be one of the
most enduring media properties of the 21st
century? Whether or not you placed money on
its success, the fourth feature-length film of the
franchise is set to debut on October 22nd, 2021.
In fact, a brand-new trailer for "Jackass Forever"
just dropped and if you're a long-time fan,
you might have noticed a disappointing absence.
The trailer for "Jackass Forever" begins with a
peppy song and title cards asking the question,
"When was the last time you got together
with old friends to laugh your asses off?"
What follows is two minutes of pure
tomfoolery as Johnny Knoxville, Steve-O,
and "Jackass" team members old and new
participate in a series of death-defying
stunts that will have you wincing in discomfort
and howling with laughter in equal measure.
It's clear, though, that one old friend
is missing from the chaos: Bam Margera.
Not only is Margera absent from the
teases for "Jackass Forever" itself,
but he's also not prominently featured in
any of the archival footage that appears
in the trailer. If you grew up watching him on
"Jackass" or his spin-off series "Viva La Bam,"
you're likely curious about his absence.
Back in February 2021, Margera posted a series of
videos to his personal Instagram page claiming,
among other things, that he had been booted
from the production of "Jackass Forever”.
Margera said in the video,
"'Jackass' does not care about me. Understand
that, ladies and gentlemen ... It was like my
family, it won't let me in because they
say I'm out there being a jackass on TMZ.
So I can't be in 'Jackass' because
I'm out there being a jackass?"
In April, TMZ followed up with Margera
about this relationship with the film.
During a taped interview, he claimed that
he was pressured by somebody in production
to do a 90-day stint in rehab, which resulted
in him being placed on a number of different
medications. Margera says this led to him
experiencing "suicidal tendencies," telling TMZ,
"What's the point of a five million
dollar contract that I have to walk on
eggshells and jump through your hoops — which
is already impossible — to obey if I'm dead?"
He called the experience "torture" and
implied that he planned on taking
legal action against production.
"It's supposed to be a f—ing reunion
... to pay our respects to Ryan Dunn."
Dunn, one of the original stars
of the franchise, died in 2011.
During his criticism of the film's production,
Margera called out several members of
the crew specifically, including Johnny
Knoxville. Director Jeff Tremaine ended up
filing a restraining order against Margera.
During a May 2021 profile in GQ, Johnny Knoxville
took the time to touch on Margera's accusations
and ultimate absence from "Jackass Forever."
Although he didn't delve deep into the details
of the situation, it's clear that the
episode was painful for Knoxville.
"We want Bam to be happy and healthy and
get the help he needs. We tried to push
that along. I think that's all I really
want to say about it ... I don't want
to get into public back-and-forth with
Bam ... I just want him to get better."
Speaking generally about mental health and
substance abuse issues that various cast
members have faced over the years, Knoxville said,
"I think each of us was responsible for
his own actions ... And when someone's
struggling, everyone tries to help that person.
And at the end of the day, that person has
to want help. Sometimes they don't. Yet."
"Jackass Forever" is slated to hit
theaters on October 22nd, 2021.
If you or anyone you know is struggling with
addiction issues, help is available. Visit the
Substance Abuse and Mental Health Services
Administration website or contact SAMHSA's
National Helpline at 1-800-662-HELP (4357).